LAURENCE MORONEY:
So now Firebase,
it's a part of Google.
But I hear that you were a part
of Firebase for a long time.
DAVID EAST: I've been with
Firebase for almost two years
now.
And I was a big user
back in the early days.
When I first discovered it,
I was building a lot of apps.
And so having something that
just made making apps so easy,
I was kind of like, my
god, they've done it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
DAVID EAST: They've built the
holy grail of development.
And then one day they posted
up a developer advocate job.
And so sent my resume
in on a Sunday,
they called me on Monday,
took a coding test on Tuesday,
flew out on Wednesday,
brought my whole family,
too, my wife and my
16-month-old son.
Got the job that day.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So the only thing
faster than the database
is the hiring committee.
DAVID EAST: Yeah, it was
a pretty fast process.
Just letting everyone know,
I was like, oh, by the way,
I'm going to San Francisco.
LAURENCE MORONEY: See you.
DAVID EAST: Yeah, pretty much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
So now you're a developer
advocate at Google and Firebase
is a part of Google.
How is that?
DAVID EAST: It's been great.
Like it's been about 15 months
ago that we were acquired.
And it's been a really
awesome experience,
because Google has just sort
of thrown a lot of resources
into us.
We've expanded the team so much.
And we've been able to
focus on the core product
and making Firebase better.
We are in the
middle of releasing
a Unity plugin that's
out there for beta,
for people to test out.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
A Unity plugin?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
Yeah, there's some
pretty cool samples.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So that's
cool stuff there, David.
I mean, how does a developer
get started with that?
DAVID EAST: So the best
place to get started
is just like right on
the Firebase website,
so Firebase.com.
And then you can sign up,
but also Firebase.com/docs.
Our docs are one of the
things that we really
pride ourselves on.
So by just reading
our quick start guide,
you can already get a gist
of how to get started.
Each platform integrates
totally with whatever
dependency manager it has.
So with Android, it's great
with Gradle, with iOS,
you can use CocoaPods.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, one of the things
I remember about Firebase
is that you guys used
to do these epic hack-a-thons
where you gave out
like really cool swag.
Is that something you still do?
DAVID EAST: Well, we used
to make a joke like Firebase
was actually a swag company and
we just kind of put on a front
that we did--
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's a swag
company that makes software.
DAVID EAST: Yeah,
that was pretty
much what we used to say.
So we used to make--
we still do actually.
We make tons of pieces of swag.
Firebase hot sauce
was pretty awesome.
My favorite is headbands.
So we have these sweatpants.
And so I was at a
hack-a-thon once
and I saw this guy who was
like, hey, can I have a couple?
And by a couple,
he meant like 16.
And then he started putting them
on and kind of like a mummified
himself and then just sat
down and started hacking.
And I was like, that
dude's going to win.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Did he?
DAVID EAST: I don't think so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: In
all seriousness, though,
I'm a developer.
Middleware is really hard.
If I want to have some
kind of a database,
if I want to have some kind
of synchronization of data,
it's a case where I can just
go out and use Firebase today,
right?
DAVID EAST: Yeah, no, I mean,
that's what we're doing.
Like we always
say our mission is
to help people build
extraordinary applications.
And so there's so many
pieces of building something.
And the back end is just so
easy to get wrong, or so easy,
you can just spend so much time.
I remember one time I was
building an Angular app.
And I was so excited.
I was like, I'm going
to write directives,
and I'm going to build
this cool web app.
And then I spent an
entire month just
building out the
back end for it.
And then I realized, I haven't
written a line of JavaScript
yet.
And so in Firebase, you
don't have that problem.
You can just
immediately start doing
what the user's interested in.
Because the user is only going
to see the client side stuff.
Like I always say,
you're never going
to get an email from an app
reviewer or someone saying,
like, hey, man.
Your app is so good.
I can tell you used
so many databases.
It's really awesome.
They're just going to tell you--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm going to
review your app with that now.
DAVID EAST: If you ever get
that review, let me know.
I would love to see it.
But most people are going to
say, the gestures were great,
or it was really responsive,
I loved this feature.
That's what people
really care about.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I mean, I've worked
for middleware companies.
And whenever we built
apps, it was a case
of we designed all the
middleware brilliantly first
and then the app was like the
thing that came at the end.
And I've worked in
purely mobile companies
and we were building
mobile apps and then
the middleware was the
thing that came at the end.
But to be able to make
that middleware easy
with the authentication,
and of course
the static hosting, which
is-- it sounds trivial
and often overlooked, but it's
actually really important.
DAVID EAST: Well,
the static hosting
is really awesome, because
the set up is so easy with it.
There is a CLI, so you
just install it on MPM.
And once you have
it installed, type
in the command Firebase
in it and that kind of
does-- it sets you up a
little file that says,
this is the Firebase database
I'm going to point to.
Or this is the URL I'm going
to set up and everything.
And then from there, you
say, Firebase deploy.
And then you have a website
out on the web, just like that.
And then every single
file is a static file,
so we actually cache
them in a CDN that
has pops all around the globe.
So wherever your users are
viewing your site from,
it's delivered to them from
whatever that local pop is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So for a
developer to get started,
Firebase.com,
tutorial's on there.
I know you've written
a series of tutorials
on some various sites, right?
DAVID EAST: Yeah, I
mean our documentation
is one of the
things that we just
pride ourselves on so much.
It was one of the
first biggest projects
I was on when we joined.
We have a quick start,
so you can get started
any platform in five minutes.
And then after that, we
have your 0 to 60 guide,
or you can go from knowing
pretty much nothing
to being an absolute pro.
And we actually take
pride in the fact
that they're written for humans
and not for technical geniuses.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Non-humans.
DAVID EAST: Yeah,
non-humans, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Cool.
Well, thank you, David.
Learned a lot.
I'm going to go check
out Firebase.com
and see what I can write
with Firebase in it.
DAVID EAST: Thanks
for having me, LoMo.
LAURENCE MORONEY: If there's
any Googlers you'd like to talk
to, contact us on our G+ page
and we'd love to put them
in front of the camera.
Thanks again.
And happy coffee.